- Hallo!
- Inge!
- Ich hätte gerne das Mittagsmenü
und ich möchte nicht nur Bohnen,
sondern auch Karotten.
- Inge, schön, dich zu sehen!
- Du wirkst mindestens
zehn Jahre jünger.
- Der Urlaub war offenbar
sehr entspannend.
- Macht euch nur lustig!
Ich erfreue mich bester Gesundheit.
Es sei denn, Alter ist eine Krankheit.
- Heißt das etwa,
der Urlaub war anstrengend?
- Ach, der Urlaub war toll.
Das Problem war das Wetter.
Je größer die
Temperaturschwankungen sind,
desto stärker spüre
ich meine Knochen.
- Ich mache dir erst mal einen Tee, dann
werden die Beschwerden gleich besser.
- Ach, das ist lieb, danke!
- Inge, wo wart ihr noch gleich?
- In Ägypten.
- In Ägypten!
- Schön!
- Ach!
- Ich hoffe, ihr wart nicht nur im Hotel,
sondern auch im Landesinneren?
- Unser Hotel war im
Landesinneren.
- Inge!
- Aber natürlich haben wir uns auch
die Sehenswürdigkeiten angeschaut.
Das Tal der Könige,
Gizeh, die Pyramiden …
- Toll!
- Ja, aber diese vielen Touristen!
Das war furchtbar!
Die alten Pharaonen würden sich
im Grabe umdrehen.
- Habt ihr etwa keinen Selfie-Stick
gekauft?
- Ha ha, Jacques wollte.
Männer werden einfach nie
erwachsen.
Ach, danke!
Ach ne, ne.